and by the way i i do think this is an
important message for men
too because i i knew that for example my
dad he passed away a couple years ago
but i i saw him struggle his whole
adult life because he did have that
thrill-seeking tendency from being a
green beret but he very much felt like
he had to stay in jobs he hated because
he was a father oh that's a good thing
he was so unhappy
and
it i've actually never
spoken about this publicly but hey this
is a good time to get this out there
that i have been in therapy about that
and i
really struggled with feeling i'm an
only child um it's interesting my
husband is an only child too we're both
only children but i even though i'm an
only child i i grew up
feeling like as much as my parents loved
me and they loved me a ton i mean like
great great great parents
but i did have this sense that
my dad's life would have been more
exciting to him if i hadn't been born
and i was also i was a surprise that my
parents didn't intend to have kids and
um
i carried that with me my whole life
this feeling that my dad he always hated
his jobs they were constantly
i mean my my association my association
with my father in work was
misery stress anxiety um i i don't think
i ever saw him happy in his work but the
met the narrative was like well i'm a
dad so i don't i don't get to like
follow my dreams or do interesting
things i haven't even thought about i
haven't even thought that that would hit
men too oh yeah
how many men
are living existences they hate because
they feel like
i have to or it pays slightly better you
have to earn more money
yeah and they think the right way to be
a dad is to make sure that every kid has
a car when they're 16 you can give them
a full ride to college they have brand
name clothes
and
so many men you know they wake up one
day and they're 50 or they're 60 and
they're like
well there there went my life you know
there went so many years out of my life
and like i
don't feel good about a lot of what i've
done like i've hated my job i've been a
wage slave and so part of my message
even though i mostly speak to women is
when when you have this kind of life
where you see
where you say that we will live an
exciting life like we're not going to be
boring you can partner with your family
and with your spouse and say hey you
know what let's actually not upgrade the
house even though it would be great to
have more room so that dad can quit this
job he hates you know what let's
downgrade the house like let's we'll
have three kids in a bedroom throw some
bunk beds in there you know i know all
these big families like four kids in a
small room that is nothing like they're
fine with that let's let's downgrade
like let's live a more free life so that
dad can start that business that he
always dreamed about doing and yes it
might be a financial disaster but let's
be with dad as he takes a shot on that
and so so men are are really in need of
that message of freedom as well and and
i think i i benefited from my husband's
experience that uh he was raised by a
single mother his father was just not
part of his life his mom i mean she
hardly made any money they were so poor
that there were times when she didn't
know what how she would get dinner i
mean they like no money poor and um
and so she wasn't able to pay for him to
go to college but you know he ended up
going to yale and having you know doing
very very well academically um but his
mom couldn't help him with any of it she
was like you're on your own for college
you're on your own for buying clothes
you have to get a job and and it was
fine and so my husband never walked in
with that expectation
that the only way to be a good parent is
to give your kids a high upper middle
class life because he was like my life
was great and i mean it was hard in a
lot of ways but he was like i my mom
couldn't pay for anything for me and all
that mattered to me as a kid is that i
had her love and i had her support and
that i was her priority in life and so
um
so
you know and i i try to support my
husband in that to not have him feel
like he has to be stuck in in jobs that
he hates
um just so that we can live a certain
lifestyle
i'm really glad we covered that maybe
that's partly what's contributing that's
got to be because i i know i grew up in
a
downtown toronto so people are pretty
liberal and nobody has kids until like
the average age of kids i don't know
maybe 33 or 34 like it's much later and
a lot of
my friends who were guys were like
you know you get me you you get married
and have a kid in your life's over right
like literally your life is over right
right and when i had scarlet and was
pregnant i can remember some of my
friends being like you do this your life
is over yeah right yep and i'm like
that's terrifying
like i don't think you're right but
that's really scary
so no i'm glad we we covered this
because i'm sure men are worried about
that too and i think my dad's got a rule
and it was in his first book i think
which is don't let your kids do anything
that makes you hate them i remember that
i read that and i was like man that's
that's solid that's really good yeah and
one of the most like insidious types i
think of hate for kids is when
it's not as outward it's like oh well
until this guy came along life was
pretty good but i love him that was that
was my dad's like and he did like he was
my biggest fan my biggest supporter but
there was this wee
constant sort of background static of
but his life was more exciting before i
came yeah so it's not in his life and
tricky yeah when i came along i think
that could also go badly like if you're
in
a relationship that's not great you
could also be like well it's not the
kid's fault it's this other person's
fault right so then that could happen
right so it's just better to try and be
aware of all those potential areas of
resentment and whatever you do
even if it feels like
it's i guess selfish then maybe it's
something to try out so that you don't
have to present for
usually if it avoids resentment i don't
think it's selfish right because being
resentful makes everyone miserable
totally well so this actually just
crystallized for me in in this moment
that i i think a very important dynamic
with this whole
women finding freedom when they have
kids is
this it's funny to you saying that just
made me realize i think a dynamic that
can come up is if your husband hates his
job but he is slogging it out every day
to so that you can stay home with the
kids or even if you don't stay home if
just you know you're trying to do the
right thing as a mom you feel all the
more pressure because if your husband is
out there like he hates what he's doing
he's not happy ever during the day he's
you know coming home just frazzled and
frustrated every single night you you
feel guilty being like well who am i i i
think subconsciously almost you're like
i should be miserable yeah you know i
could you know get this book deal i
could do this writing project while i'm
staying home with the kids but i'd
better be doing things that make me
miserable because how unfair would that
be if i'm like following my passions and
living my best life well my husband is
punching the clock in a job that he
despises and i i just now kind of
remembered that this was something that
my husband and i had to go through when
things were taking off for me with
writing and i was really in the zone and
and using that you know blue flame
it he hated his job and there was this
unspoken tension of like okay
we need to even this out a little bit i
shouldn't have all the joy you know yeah
and so that was when we started talking
about doing the tour finding better ways
to monetize my career i said look i it's
going to take me a few months to
monetize this to the point that you
might be able to scale back the amount
of work that you're doing so that you
can go you know he loves sailing you
know go explore that passion a little
bit more and it did i mean it took about
a year before i could shift things with
my
income so that i could monetize this
work that i was doing
but then it became this really beautiful
thing where we were partnering together
financially yeah where neither one of us
had to live a life that we hated where
each one of us could wake up and say wow
i'm really looking forward to this day
like i have things i'm passionate about
this is great and and it again it was a
very intentional process and it took a
long time of us working together to
figure out how to make that work for
both of us but it is a really beautiful
thing when you can hook that up